E desde criança eu escuto um pensamento
confuso que hoje eu sei que ele tem o
grande objetivo de negar direitos
é um pensamento que é reproduzido na
nossa sociedade
no qual os direitos fundamentais dos
cidadãos e das cidadãs eles são
constantemente violados e essa violação
ela favorece privilégios para aquele
grupo que se beneficia exatamente da
construção do discurso e da reprodução
esse mesmo pensamento equivocado que é a
violação dos direitos fundamentais de
todos os cidadãos e cidadãs que são os
direitos humanos
Tá bom eu algum tempo atrás tive o
prazer de conhecer uma pessoa que e
várias pessoas na minha trajetória que
me ajudaram a entender um pouco de onde
eu vim o que eu sou e o que eu posso
representar dentro daquilo que penso ser
importante para melhorar a vida em
sociedade Quer dizer então que nós somos
frutos eu sou fruto de um conjunto de
pessoas também que me ajudaram a
perceber é a vida em sociedade de forma
diferente daquilo que o estado que o
nosso país permitiu a várias gerações de
pessoas da minha cor de pele a pessoas
negras e negros
e nós tivemos aqui do nosso país
o Tratado de Tordesilhas
depois tivemos o descobrimento em 1500
um pouco mais na frente nós tivemos em
1822 a proclamação da Independência do
Brasil
e naquele momento os nós sabemos o país
passava por um processo ainda de
escravidão a grande força de trabalho
que gerou riquezas nosso país
é a essência do capitalismo brasileiro
ele ainda se baseou na força de trabalho
de pessoas escravizadas nos países diga
sim pessoas indígenas mas os negros que
aqui vieram trabalhar de forma é forçada
de um outro continente para Continente o
nosso continente
em 1822 nós estávamos um processo aonde
já existia uma
a Revolução Industrial já havia
acontecido a Inglaterra ela
necessariamente é o brigava os países né
Para que abrisse mercados para que a
força de trabalho escravo fosse abolida
e o Brasil
aceitou em 1822 condicionando que a sua
independência fosse aceita também pela
Inglaterra e daí se deu um
é um
conceito que quando se fala se isso é
para inglês ver
então o Brasil assinou o Tratado mas na
verdade só aboliu a escravidão em 1888
então de 1822 até 1888 apesar do tratado
isso não ocorreu no Brasil o que ocorreu
foi que um pouco mais na frente em
1871 tivemos a lei do ventre livre e
essa lei eu pensava algum tempo atrás
que a pessoa nasceu naquele período já
era livre mas não era assim a pessoa
nascia trabalhava como escravo 21 anos a
sua vida e quando chegava nos 21 anos o
proprietário de escravos tinha direito
de ir a coroa e para libertar aquela
pessoa pedir uma indenização a coroa
indenizando aquele negro alforriado não
indenizando essa pessoa trabalhava mais
cinco anos da sua vida como escravos ou
seja com 26 anos ele poderia ser
considerado uma pessoa Livre
é um pouco mais na frente vemos a lei
dos sexagenários mais próximo da posição
da escravatura e eu pensava bom chegou
aos 60 anos tá livre mas também não era
assim a pessoa chegar vou 60 anos ou
proprietário de escravos tinha direito
de chegar na monarquia e pedir
indenização daquelas pessoas caso isso
não ocorresse essa pessoa Tinha que
trabalhar mais três anos da sua vida
veja bem com 60 anos será praticamente
impossível naquela época na condição de
escravo e depois era depois tivemos um
pouco mais na frente abolição da
escravatura em 1888 E também tivemos em
1889 a proclamação da república EA
proclamação da república foi exatamente
momento um ano depois da abolição da
escravatura na qual os senhores de
escravos também chegaram a Princesa
Isabel e descobriram que não ia ter
indenização bom então e se juntaram pô
aqueles que queriam a proclamação da
república expulsar a família real do
Brasil que eu quero dizer com isso é que
a construção de um projeto de nação a
partir de 1889 do Brasil ele não
incorporou os negros e negras na
história na construção econômica do
nosso país o que se teve a partir daí
ainda é um estado no qual a grande
maioria dessas pessoas e aí Mirage foi
extremamente feliz na fala dele é a
produção da exclusão ou seja se o
sistema escravocrata brasileiro gerou
riquezas para alguns ele gerou miséria
exclusão social para milhões de outras
pessoas por gerações de pessoas
e até aqui a minha fala ela vai se dando
do meu momento de compreensão política
do que eu estou dizendo eu só fui
começar a entender o que eu estou
falando aqui agora em 1999 recentemente
quando eu já tinha meus trinta e poucos
anos de idade que eu fui descobrir que
um dos grandes motivos que me pedia de
poder avançar ainda estava atrelada a
uma condição social que a crê-lo milhões
de pessoas no nosso país que é a questão
ainda da cor da pele no Brasil
e nós podemos dizer que não é por aí mas
o racismo brasileiro ele maqueia por
exemplo desafio senhores e as senhoras
se vocês olharem qualquer dicionário
brasileiro e pegar o significado de
preto e o significado de branco nós
vamos ver que a construção estrutural do
racismo está a partir dali
indivíduo perigoso
homem da Raça Negra Preto sujo encardido
está no nosso dicionário a
Oi e aí eu fico entendendo porque que a
polícia né na maioria das abordagens
policiais também eles vêm os negros e
nós mesmo aí andando nas Ruas a gente vê
como as pessoas que na verdade são os
mais perigosos porque culturalmente isso
está colocado para nós nosso cotidiano
na nossa formação educacional
tá bom
e com essa história eu conheci Milton
Gonçalves que um dia me falou José
Eduardo você tem que parar de ser do
movimento negro
A grande diferença hoje está em ser um
negro em movimento
isso a diferença conceitual diferente
porque essa ideia de ser um negro
movimento e sair do movimento negro
traduzir-se na ideia de não ficar
fazendo denúncia de que a sociedade
havia racismo
mais passar a lutar para o protagonismo
na sociedade na qual Mega os mesmos
direitos a pessoas na minha cor e aos
pobres nosso país também
então passei a compreender isso e nessa
trajetória
nós eu vivia de atuação política
de intervenção social
me formei em serviço social que também
me ajudou muito na compreensão dos
espaços quais nossa e quando
bom e quando foi ainda lá atrás em 1981
no início dos anos 80 houve ocupação do
setor finsocial e naquele momento é a
minha mãe nós morávamos na beira de um
córrego aqui conhece em Cuba e lá ela
foi para o finsocial foi morar lá a
diferença é que aqui na região central
próximo do Setor Funcionários ela era
empregada doméstica mulher negra
analfabeta naquela época então ali ela
podia o seu Labor era trabalho doméstico
quanto nós mudamos para o setor
finsocial no início dos anos 80 todas as
pessoas que ali moravam também não
tinham condições de pagar alguém para
fazer trabalho doméstico é o fato é que
a situação obrigou sair de lá e voltar
de novo para o setor dos funcionários e
que com o decorrer desse processo
né Nós entrei na luta por moradia
e da luta por moradia no final do início
dos anos 90 a 96 a prefeitura aqui de
Goiânia criou um baixa mas Goiânia Viva
Residencial Goiânia Viva e todas as
pessoas que haviam nós morávamos estava
com trajetória da luta daquelas pessoas
também foram convidadas né ganharam é um
terreno no Residencial Goiânia Viva
então isso também me despertou a ideia
de que dar importância da relação do
cidadão com poder público Ora se nós
queremos transformar mudar nós temos que
está nos Espaços que tomasse decisões
então espaço público é um espaço
importante para isso
o e de
99 um pouco mais na frente iniciou-se
uma luta aqui em Goiânia ela é isso
ainda não usa no final dos anos 80 uma
luta aqui em Goiânia para a questão da
incorporação nas políticas públicas da
cidade de Goiânia da temática racial e
uma delas foi a criação foi a luta pela
criação do Conselho Municipal na época
dos direitos do negro isso em 88 me
lembro o vereador mosair Morais que
apresentou o projeto de lei e um grupo
de militantes foi lá o pé direito negro
vamos a defender Eu fui também né o fato
é que de 88 somente em 2000 e somente em
e é que nós conseguimos a sanção da
criação de Um Conselho Municipal que
chamou chamava-se chamou-se de chamas
conferir Conselho Municipal de promoção
da Igualdade racial então foi um
conjunto de uma luta a mudança de
conceito de direitos do negro para
igualdade racial A diferença é que no
conceito igualdade racial se tornava
Algo Mais amplo considerando que não só
os negros na nossa sociedade mas os
indígenas e os ciganos e outras etnias
mas basicamente as três etnias ela
sofrem diretamente o peso da sua conta
da sua condição étnica na nossa
sociedade e criou-se então o Conselho
Municipal de promoção da Igualdade
racial em 2004
e nessa luta na trajetória na
participação em governos e em 2008 fui
convidado para atuar como assessor de
polícia os pratos descendência na
Prefeitura de Goiânia e naquele momento
meu conceito era o mesmo é necessário
mudar e aí nós trabalhamos foi feita
alteração de conceito de
afrodescendentes para Conselho Municipal
de promoção da Igualdade racial o
incorporação e que sangue várias outras
pessoas ainda que tá aqui na plateia
também nos ajudou muito nisso que foi a
ideia de incorporar à luta da Igualdade
racial junto com a cultura de paz né uma
divergência que havia porque muitas
pessoas achavam que não a questão dos
negros tenta separado e ainda tem esse
pensamento mas nós entendíamos que
precisava incorporar outras lutas e o
resultado desse processo foi o final a
construção da Secretaria Municipal de
promoção da Igualdade racial em 2012 na
que existe na cidade de Goiânia e a
mensagem que eu acho que eu gostaria de
de passar aqui é que vale muito a partir
de nós a crença de que sociedade nós
queremos tá que rumo nós queremos seguir
um país aonde A grande maioria que está
entre a 20ª ou o nosso país está entre
os países onde mais se assassina os
jovens Goiânia a nossa cidade é oitavas
a 28ª capital mais violenta E sendo que
a grande maioria dos jovens que são
assassinados não só em Goiânia mas no
país ainda são jovens negros eu teria um
monte de outras coisas para poder falar
a partir daí mas para finalizar minha
mãe tempos atrás nós conseguimos
passando esse processo todo Compramos
uma casa e aí ela tava na porta da casa
e chegou a vendedora e ela lá
trabalhando a vendedora perguntou para
ela sim e o Dona
Eu trabalho com isso com isso a senhora
pode me apresentar a dona da casa e a
minha mãe a dona da casa como é que tava
lá na porta e minha mãe fica p da vida
com isso aí mais calma mano só uma
sociedade Onde os negros ainda são
vistos como subalternos então durante
boa parte dos anos ainda nós iremos
ouvir mesmo estando em posições nas
quais seria natural qualquer cidadão
qualquer cidadã mas o fato da nossa cor
ainda nos impede ser visto como pessoas
que também tem as mesmas condições
sociais de qualquer outro brasileiro e
brasileira
Oi e essa discussão é
ela
Tomara que não seja né por isso que
foram criadas as políticas afirmativas e
nós imaginamos que elas devem ser
políticas temporárias mas que também
permita corrigir as distorções que foram
construídas ao longo da história do
nosso país distorções nas quais sempre
beneficiou a mesma classe econômica e
essa classe econômica para que nós
possamos mudar o nosso país é preciso
incorporar
incorporar todas as pessoas dos cidadãos
e cidadãs a partir dos seus melhores
talentos das suas melhores condições e
isso eu acredito que é uma forma de
lutar contra o racismo Muito obrigado
E aí